hello I'm gav I'm Dan we're back at the
Colorado School of mins our favorite
place for blowing things up it'd be a
crime I feel like if we didn't do
something on this trip with a shape
charge it is a crime we've done them
every single time we've been here mhm
here's
one what here's
another I like him another there's
another there you go whoa wow every time
say follow we done it we've only done it
with one charge so I thought this time
how about we get two charges and point
them at at each other make them fight
fight for those who haven't seen a shape
charge video What's a shape charge Dan
it's a an explosive where you start the
explosion here and there's some
explosives packed behind this focusing
copper liner what it does is it causes
from the rear the focused jet to appear
it kind of inverts the cone and these
are used for making holes in things like
steel or Earth or concrete or rock or
tanks or whatever really and that's done
just entirely from the shape that it
starts at correct as always these events
are incredibly fast we've got some
serious gear again there's a phantom
recording in 4k 1,000 frames a second
that's just a witnessing the whole thing
it'll probably be completely useless for
analyzing the shape charge over here
we've got the shimatsu last time we ran
this at 5 million frames a second to see
the cone fly out might run it faster
today and then over here the TMX which
I'm going to start around 880,000 frames
a second and then maybe push up
to 400 nice thin slip okay before get
into the multiples we thought maybe
we'll just fire one off get an idea for
exposure Y into a lovely block of
ballistic gel that's right this is also
20% ballistic gel rather than the 10% we
used before
so oh solid meaty and I just have no
idea of what's going to happen yeah cuz
when we send big old rounds from an
elephant gun through it the hole of
Entry is so wide temporarily it
stretches out massively yeah but I don't
really know if this is going to do this
it's like obviously way more velocity
but there's not a lot of mass there's
less MK but there'll be more pressure
yeah so yeah I have no idea you ready
ready all right fire in the hole fire in
the hole fire in the
hole really good pop y wa look what it's
done to the table it's done more to the
table than it has to the thing that it
was fired at that is insane cuz it's
never black on the inside that is cool
by the way did it just like dribble out
the end it's made a grim looking melty
hole in it though oh that looks like
that looks like the beginning of a raid
in Destiny that's somehow I've walked
into
that that's somehow the biggest hole
we've made look at the pattern here
that's the fragmentation patter here
yeah super cool that's great I wonder
how much it expanded oh yeah let's have
a look first shot of the
day bloody so fast that was rapid I just
I'm so used to bullets I'll be honest I
was not expecting that to be gone so
quickly wao so is that the tip look how
quickly it dims it doesn't have any
brightness in there but and it's gone
yeah now we're just looking at explosion
the brightness is completely gone look
at that shock wave in there it's got
like a big bow wave but it's causing all
this rip this bubbling cavitation W that
is fascinating so it lost a lot of its
mass a lot of its content is now stuck
in this channel but the tip of it even
though not Bri here relights it's
basically and it's left of it is still
going look at how tiny that actual sort
of jet point is you basically got to see
that react with two different mediums
and but it switched back and forth that
was really cool that was so cool I love
that speaking of very fast things I'd
now like to briefly talk about Opa
desktop browser who have very kindly
agreed to sponsor this section of the
video Opera desktop browser is a very
fast privacy and Security based internet
browser my favorite feature is the
built-in VPN it's right there on the
address bar I've used lots of separate
os-based vpns in the past but a lot of
them have caused me issues with seeing
other things on my own network and
because all my Phantoms connect to my
machines with ethernet it can also stop
them from showing up the fact that it's
a VPN built into the browser means I can
very easily appear as though I'm
somewhere else to other websites but it
doesn't mess with all the stuff on my
own network conveniently it's free and
unlimited it also has Arya a generative
AI service with real time access to the
web to answer questions and generate
content I've used Arya to translate
comments on our videos from other
languages so I understand what
everyone's on about as well as doing all
my recent unit conversions from metric
to American I've also found tab Islands
incredibly useful in keeping all my
stuff together especially when I'm
buying props for videos and you can drag
the entire Island around which is very
convenient where other websites struggle
with stuttering and lag on Modern
websites Opera priz itself on its smooth
browsing experience you can try out the
OPA desktop browser by clicking the link
in the description I'm very thankful for
for them sponsoring this video These
expensive videos are incredibly
difficult to make without a sponsor so
massive thanks to them now it's time to
make two shape charges fight each other
okay this is Contender number one in the
Red Corner got this guy he's going to go
over this hole here all right and we've
lined these up with lasers to try and
get them as accurate as possible because
when they're this far apart the points
the very finest points are tiny yeah so
there's going to be a lot of sort of
extra stuff happening here and like a
lot of bright and Gump but we're going
to try and get the Jets to meet in the
middle just going to go straight for it
yep good luck fire in the hole fire in
the hole fire in the
hole very satisfying did you hear like
a oh what was that maybe it was some
sort of Ricochet or something something
spinning maybe oh goodness oh they've
been hit on the side what's happened
here they must have hit because or
something cuz there's two holes there's
there's three sort of holes here and
then I wonder if that's just one here I
wonder if that's just from a straight
jet or whether there was like an impact
that caused them to split and go
slightly deviated this is this is
interesting yeah this is like a larger
kind of like sideways hole like it looks
like it's been sort of technically it
should be just one straight hole right
but there's three separate ones and one
like one here and dear dear look at our
absolute battery of
[Laughter]
cameras Oh it's
over was that like one frame oh look at
that Bloody massive piece of shrap that
just digs out of the slabber
there yeah there's a lot more shrap than
I thought there would be actually
playing back ready
yep
wa what that is instant look at that why
is it blue is that what is that it might
just be like a certain wavelength of
light that is JJ that is like two death
stars like a quick draw with two death
stars know when someone gets like uh
when Thor gets like sucked up by the the
bridge that's what it looks like the
bifrost yeah he looks like a bifrost h
know like Thor just about to step out of
it that is absolutely so let's see what
we can see there's shock waves that are
coming from the entire width of that
they're coming they're like meeting oh
yeah it's like a sausage shock hold on
you can see if you rewind it and play
back the the blue Parts with the the
flaring you can see them going past each
other it actually they it does get
brighter they did they collided in the
middle they did otherwise it would have
stayed the same brightness yeah but then
still some of it carried on like we
didn't completely Collide them both
there was still lots of stuff carrying
on cuz you can see it the opposite side
so definitely want to go tight on that
and underexpose and I wonder if we'll
see any impact I think it's still going
to be too bright but I'll try and
underexpose it I can't believe that I
want to do it again let's do it again
all right cool yeah and there's that one
that we saw plink off the off the rock
making some new dents should we uh sign
it I should you should write your name
by it
yeah look like a radial blur what's all
this here this is all oh again fragment
like that's where the the V was welded
on to hold it yeah it seems that we put
little V's on here to hold the shape
charger they just shared off immediately
they've just beded
down
oh no this one got Reed this TMX just
took it in the mouth that is wild did
any of the other oh this one wow it's so
deep in it's like they've got the
perfect width they know what they're
doing oh you can feel it can you it's
bulged the inside it's bulged it's
bulged by like that
that's scary close it just shows you
that how much sheer fragmentation is in
the back of the shape charge the the
cylinder all of this sandbag stuff all
that there yeah it's just a mess making
it's basically a frag grenade that fires
a bullet essentially yeah it's a frag
grenade that fires one focused bullet
basically yeah nothing on the screen
whatsoever complete pitch black 375,000
FPS 333 nond exposure okay and I I've
just not I think it's going to still be
too right
wow that is a nice speed
though that's am
amazing it actually they kind of just
brush each other don't they wow and then
and I love the uh the shape charge
hitting the cloud at the back and
lighting it up like back lighting the
explosive the other side and look how
just dark the regular explosion is it's
immediately gone out this stays bright
all the way through like all the way to
the other side I love how it gets
brighter when they coll when they
Collide right it doubles the brightness
look what's quite interesting is that as
we get a shorter duration exposure the
glow from the jet is skinnier yeah so
like as we stop down we're even though
we're in the same place we're just going
to get a more narrow jet so I'm going to
have to push this
camera the lowest I can go on shutter
speed is 95 NS 95 the rest will have to
be done in the lens I'm already at f8
I'm going have to go to F22 and then
that's it then we're into like neutral
density territory which I've never used
for slowmo I've never end slow-mo before
so this is going to be the darkest
you've ever gone like the this will be
the darkest this camera can go this is
amazing absolutely
incredible oh wow here we go oh they
just missed each other wao what's
happening there I've seen this on other
cameras actually if if the subject is
too bright it just inverses the value of
the pixel like it rolls over from 255 to
zero so that actually might be the
brightest area of the image like a
negative yeah I think that's just the
exact points of collision we need to
drastically reduce the light intake of
both cameras here the um shimatsu will
now be at 200 nond exposure but F32 and
six stops of neutral density so if we
lose it on this we'll hope get it there
okay so back to a 375,000 frames a
second shut it all the way down to 95
NS and the
lens all the way down to F22 we're
throwing all of our equipment of this
all of it if I can't film it like this I
can't film it I need to go shopping all
right just s to the shops yeah get some
bed D's okay are you ready I am ready
okay far in the hole far in the hole far
no we got to check if the camera
survived as
well yeah cuz last time there was lots
of bits camera survival Priority One
yeah footage retention priority two yeah
what's priority three lunch
[Applause]
yeah what a silly
problem it should be some sort of
software on there that does it for you
there is but need the soft
oh wa you really pick up more detail
there don't you see all of this stuff
that's now orange was Pure White before
and and it's still do you know when
someone gets out like a flaming sword
yeah you know like it looks like two
people getting out flaming swords what's
crazy is that the massive bright
explosion that is on the back of the
shape charge is now just like a little
puff yeah that is that is a bright
explosion as well bright explosion
that's essentially High explosives like
like C4 you know you can see now that
because we're seeing the jet it's only
the tip that's the brightest part this
was entirely white and now we're seeing
detail in just the front this is blowing
out wow glancing blow yeah it was a it
was a not quite perfect shot no but it's
not easy it's not easy but that was
definitely an impact so this is as dark
as I can make it without going and
buying some NDS still blown out so we
should go and check out the shimatsu
which was going at 2 million and was Ed
to
Oblivion who there's like the tiniest
little bit at the front so this is with
all our ND and we finally exposed the
tip we can finally clearly see the tip
of the shape charge I've never seen that
before I've never seen that before I had
I thought it would be more like a jet
but it's literally just like a Teensy
little tip yeah the front tip is always
just such a small surface area it's
minuscule and these miss each other by
millimet but obviously all of this side
material still collides and you can see
it brightening up I mean it's very
faintly brightening but you know to our
eyes it was lighting up the whole frame
that part what's interesting to me is
that the sort of cloud behind that
initial tip was blown out on our footage
like the whole Cloud but that shows that
the tip is even brighter than that cloud
you wouldn't be able to tell that from
our footage yeah exactly I love it's
still bright at the very front it's it's
whatever powder is pushing through and
hitting the air is what is bright but
that is the only bit that's Max
brightness all these areas of Blackness
were where we were starting to see
orange and all the area of white is what
we can see in this shimasu shot it's
almost like it's been it's perfect do
you know what I mean yeah I mean the
only thing the only stuff we can't see
here is the color but that is all the
detail that's fast
so probably only missed by a few M there
but unfortunately that was our final
attempt due to uh lightning coming over
again what's interesting about that is
is that we lined it up with lasers and
it looks like they missed by miles but
they've missed by such a small amount
it's so small all right remember last
time we saw the shape charge start to
form at 5 million frames a second yeah I
asked them to cheekily grab one looking
straight down the barrel from the very
beginning of the explosion at 10 million
frames a second 10 million this is
actually as fast as the shimatsu could
go you ready for
this wow
no that Wicked that's insane footage
like that just shows you how did they
know this by the way like how did they
know that this happened without watching
this like you watch this and you're like
oh yeah yeah I can see how that kind of
works how did they know I guess I
thought that the jet would come just
shoot forwards but you actually have
this shock wave igniting all the copper
around the the rim like it all hits the
front but the jet at the back is still
behind that and then it hits so it it
like hits itself before it really comes
out of the door and also this part here
from the very first flash to where it
hits the front happens in 65 frames at
10 million so that's 6.5 microc seconds
of time well even though we've done
shape charges multi times at this point
that was definitely the most fascinating
footage we've got out of it that was
your favorite that was my favorite by
far turns out when you do shape charge
versus shape charge the winner is
us it was weird stepping down the
exposure like as we got darker and short
duration on each exposure the glow
became smaller until eventually you
could just see the tip it's just the tip
that's hot I mean the whole thing's hot
and bright but it must be that very
front layer cuz it's moving so quickly
so it's constantly presenting a new
Surface to the air stuff in like the
middle of the cone is coming to the
front as the stuff at the front goes out
to The Sid exactly yeah that was
mindblowing it's like brighter than 100
Suns it was so bright that the explosion
was like nothing like a puff of smoke
pretty much big old thanks to the
Colorado School of Minds for letting us
come here and supplying us with the
appropriate amount of shape charges
there's links in the description to the
stuff they do if you're interested here
are some other videos that we've made
here thanks for watching